Ericka's with us in Houston
hi Erica how are you better than that
how can I help myself in kind of a bad
situation I have a car loan of about
12,000 sorry I'm trying not to cry okay
what else I've got about 8,000 in credit
cards and I am currently unemployed I'm
looking very aggressively for a job I
actually applied for some of your jobs
this morning and I got on your website
but my parents really are pushing me to
go back to school and finish my degree
and take out student loans to do that
and I just really it doesn't make sense
to me to take out more debt are these
your only two that's your only two - yes
okay and what were you making about
36,000 and when did you lose that job in
July okay all right and you're how old
27 okay and you're single
yes I am and your parents live where
nearby me okay and are you living with
them or are you trying to pay the
apartment rent or whatever no job I am
currently crashing on a friend's couch
because I don't know what else to do
right where were you living I had a
house at least with my boyfriend but we
broke up and police ended and I you sure
you don't you know so you don't have
that responsibility or that problem okay
a lot of volatility in your life right
now kiddo
I know I can see why you're scared
understand what what is your what were
you studying when you were in college
it's called integrative studies where
you pick three fields mine words like
counseling and business mm-hmm and how
far are you from finishing your degree
it would take me about a year oh good
okay that's good news I what will it
cost I don't know I'm sorry that's okay
that's okay I think it's for I think
it's worth looking into to figure out
what it would cost because you're that
close to the finish line I can see the
tape you all you get is run through the
line right I can see that I can see then
the race you're almost there you're only
a year away my goodness right now it
seems like a pile of money away in a
problem away and all these other things
you're homeless and got car payments and
credit cards and everything else so I
agree with you I think you've got good
gut instincts I would not tell you to go
into student loan debt what I would tell
you to do is start anything you can
start today you have a car let's deliver
pizzas let's go find somebody and
babysit for them let's start to get any
kind of money we can get coming in
quickly just to kind of get some of the
panic away from your from you okay
don't worry about your credit cards I
don't want them to get behind but if
anything gets behind it's those you eat
first you pay your car payment and keep
gas in at second and you work at
anything you can get work at immediately
waiting tables you can walk in Houston's
got a and it got a labor shortage right
now it's not hard to find work there now
you may not find what you're looking for
but I don't care if you're shoveling
sawdust on a construction site you need
to be working by Friday because it'll
make you some money and you won't have
time to be scared okay then let's get
you back into a little apartment and
then let's get your career moving again
and then go finish school with cash
after you get to making a little bit
better money but your first goal is just
get some kind of something coming in as
quickly as possible
to find' the fear off and so yeah go go
right now 2 3 pizza places and by the
end of day you'll be delivering pizzas
you can make 1,500 a month delivering
pizzas at night then during the day
start driving over you just got two jobs
just like that now then you go from
there
we'll build it rebuild again